hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jesse I'm Jesse and I am trying to
stream from home again today so I got my
internet upgraded and I made some
changes to my settings on OBS but I'm
still getting occasionally some some
issues so let me know on your end how
this this looks what kind of quality are
you getting and and we'll see I there's
still a few more things that I could try
so if it gets bad you know it may be
able to fix it but today we are going to
work on that search page that we were
working on yesterday so yesterday we
worked on styling the search bar and we
styled the sorting drop down and the the
filters the check box filters so I don't
know if style would be the right word we
we arrange them differently so we laid
it out differently so today I'd like to
focus on styling the actual results so
right now they look a mess and I'll
switch over to them now because I think
I look a mess the only thing I do want
to show you when I'm in this view is my
cool shirt so I get this shirt from my
grandma
okay Christmastime powered by ramen so
anyway I'm a ramen fan let me switch
over now
ok cool now we'll be able to see the
code
make it a bit bigger and I was working
on the routing I I did make some pretty
interesting changes to the routing
function so if you want to check out
what I've done look at the last thing
that was let's see if I did this kid all
right so I just now pushed these changes
so the last commit that this pushed up
to the repo has some changes to be able
to handle some different situations
particularly when we have two parameters
for our routing in our server touch a s
file so I added a lot of comments to try
to make it easier to understand so
someone can ask me at the end of the
stream if you want me to go through this
I'm not going to right now but hopefully
the comments will help you if you want
to check out on your own the link to the
repo should be in the description all
right so let's go over and go over to
the search page I've been slowly going
through every link I could find on every
page in making sure that the data slugs
are correct in WordPress and that the
the router handles it correctly so it's
this pin it's kind of slow going because
occasionally you'll run into something
and I'm like are you serious that URL is
why why is it like that and they don't
have to go back and that's why I had to
add some logic into the router to handle
this case that I had found all right so
we're gonna go on to the search page and
every one thing I have noticed and we
noticed it a little bit the last time I
try to stream from home is that
everything is slower so even if the
stream is okay everything else on this
machine is slower so if it gets too bad
I may end up either using a different
machine completely I have a Windows desk
that might be better or it's possible
and the guy I believe was it Matthew
yeah I think his name was Matthew who
would help I mentioned yesterday he'd
help me out he said that it's possible
to run OBS on a completely different
machine network as my laptop and then
all the streaming stuff would be handled
by that machine and then I would just
handle the you know actually building
the stuff so that might be the best
solution I just need to get that all set
up on the other computer which currently
is on the other side of my house right
now so I'll have to figure some way to
make that work okay all right Blake hey
everybody I see Oh on the chat here so
Blake asked for a speed test yeah maybe
we'll do a speed test later on remind me
towards the end of the streamer on the
next break about knowing a speed test
it's not spectacular the best internet I
can get here is 25 on the upload and 25
on the download and 5 on the upload so
still not great but I even asked like
you have anything else and they said no
that's the the highest we can go so so
that's what we have literally the best
money can buy all for stream Mickey says
speed test while streaming is not a good
idea ok yeah good call so anyway those
are I'll tell you what the results of my
speed test were after I upgraded I think
I was getting like a little over 3 on
the upload and the download was some it
was like 17 so you know how that work
she never really get what they would
they say all right so we do have the
search page up now and I'm gonna start
my Pomodoro timer we're gonna do a
25-minute Pomodoro session where we code
after that we'll take a 5 minute break
and
answer any questions that are in the
live chat and we're just going to go
back and forth we'll do two Pomodoro
sessions today unless for some reason we
just fly through this and make
everything look perfect
within the first 25 minutes then we'll
only do one and then at the end I'll
take all the rest of the time to answer
questions and let's see I'm just
checking what's in the chat right now
all right great so it seems like the
streams doing well I've got no weird
messages about it from OBS so yeah most
of the users are getting 720p so most
you're getting 720p which is great
that's what I'm shooting for all right I
think this is doable so let's search for
something I keep searching for biology
so why not just keep going and search
for biology all right so why did
anthropology come up immediately when I
searched biology oh I guess the word
biology must be in there somewhere so
here's our search results I was ooh min
so right now we're getting the category
which is major although I talked to my
boss and evidently it's it's really the
department and not necessarily the major
so the title on the current website said
major departments or department majors
or something like that there was or no
programs I'm sorry these are programs so
they said major programs so I think
we're gonna go with calling them
programs instead for now I'm gonna stick
with majors there's no sense in me
changing everything unless I'm a hundred
percent sure
so anyway the categories is major we see
here here's a category for department so
we're displaying categories we're
displaying the date
which we may or may not even want to
display I just needed this displayed
when we were testing our sorting and
then the title we had talked weeks ago
about also displaying a a small
description I don't I don't know that
that's the best idea right now because
there's a lot of pieces of content that
don't have either don't have a
description or worse they have a really
weird description that's formatted weird
it has strange HTML tags in it and even
if we remove the HTML tags it would look
even worse so I don't think we can do
that now so the first thing we're gonna
do is just make it look good with the
category and the title potentially the
dates the dates really don't matter
right now though because a lot of the
content came over and they'll all have
like the date when it was imported over
to the new database and not the actual
published date so I don't know we'll see
so I think that's all we're gonna have
right now for the search results it's
gonna be a little bear
at some point it'd be great to get
reasonable excerpts and descriptions for
each page that comes up in these results
but that's it just depends on you know
who I can get to do that I mean I
certainly don't think it's a good use of
my time to go through and try to write
that right now alright so let's do that
I don't really have any inspiration that
I'm going with here or any vision in my
head so I'm just gonna we're just gonna
like get this design going as we go so
I'm open to to any suggestions that you
all have and that Angie says excited to
watch this I've never done a code
before I'm such a new don't worry about
it we're uh I'm a noob to at many things
so I'm glad that you here in the live
chef feel free to ask any questions that
that pop up I'm happy to go over
anything if I'm being confusing or
anything like that
alright so let's pull out this date
first that'll do a lot to clean it up
because it states ugly go over to the
code let me know if this code is not big
enough I may have to go bigger than
normal because I can't get 1080p quality
at home search and I'm gonna get rid of
as much as I can okay so here's where
were below right oh no I yeah we moved
our check boxes below the the results
okay so here's our results so here's the
actual markup and we just used some days
we didn't even use any material UI
components for right now I think this is
okay I I don't think I want to make
cards for each one of these we can try
it if whatever we come up with right now
doesn't really look great we can try to
do cards but I don't think I think it'll
just look cleaner like this so we'll see
see how it goes so let's pull out the
date right now we'll get rid of that if
we do that it back in later we'll
definitely make it look a lot nicer than
it did we currently have where's there's
the type here let's see the type is a
slightly different color it's a little
bit gray but
it might not be a bad idea to make this
an entirely different color to maybe
have it stand out a bit more so color
schooi egg this see what color we have
we can make it this gold color let's see
what it looks like with the gold and so
we already have the classes type on here
so we could just add to that class I
think that's what we'll do all the way
up we have type and let's go with color
and color do we have is it like theme I
don't I'm not sure exactly what it's
called but let's try theme API oops not
API what I'm thinking theme color
secondary let's see if that works and I
forgot a comma that's why I'm getting
that red error line
Nikki says if a different color that
same yellow is the student profile yes I
thought about that did anything happen
no nothing happened I wonder if we're
using that I may have to look up what
that is supposed to be
I wonder if it'll give me I guess we can
look at material you eye documentation
Aniki I think you're right we could go
with that color but I want to see how
the gold looks so I that yellow
sometimes is a bit hard to to make out
on especially on older monitors so if
the if the gold looks okay I think I'm
gonna go with the gold and then we may
end up changing the cards as well on the
homepage secondary alright yeah that was
undefined
I don't see it'll tell us
how it okay maybe we gotta go paladins
so we'll go theme pallet secondary see
if that works
have you smoked pallet tal ET te i know
it didn't look right
secondary alright that looks better
let's try it now see what we have should
be getting a refresh soon I guess while
I'm waiting for the refresh I'm gonna
look back in the Angie says is this a
class with the font settings on its own
yes so Angie I'm not sure how much you
know about react so this is probably
gonna look weird
let me see okay John I see John's
already answered so I'll just kind of
add to that as well so in react one of
the ways you can do Styles is to make a
JavaScript object with CSS like property
so you can see this is it looks kind of
like CSS but we're doing some stuff like
camel casing so I am just making a class
called type basically and I'm setting
the color to whatever color we have
saved basically in as as this so instead
of putting the hex value like we
normally would then hey Ambrose but my
three-year-old is trying to try to get
over here Ambrose we can't watch any
shows right now I'm doing a live stream
on YouTube okay
so anyway so that's all we're doing you
know very very similar to what we do
normally with CSS just to add the color
to the class so yeah hey finally so
let's search and see hmm we did not work
let's check out what's going on here in
dev tools and see why it's not working
for us so I need let's get rid of the
console here at the bottom you don't
need that but we do need this and let's
move this over okay all right so it
looks like our color is not working I
messed something up when I mess up theme
palette secondary oh I know what I
messed up check this out so secondary
what does return on objects just just
like it it says here I was looking right
at it and just didn't realize it so I
need to add main in order to return a
string
I was trying I was pulling in this
entire object which obviously you know
you can't pass objects as CSS property
values so let's go with main and that
should give us like the color in the
color palette that we want Michael
Creole says Ambrose in the house yeah it
was Ambrose was trying to come in yeah
Ambrose has been sad all day cuz he just
wants to sit here in my chair with me
and he wants me to put my little pony on
one of my monitors I have three monitors
here okay so our secondary color is that
yellow color interesting see yeah that's
really hard to read like that we could
maybe change the font weight and it
might be a bit better but anyway I've
been what I've been doing I've actually
been using all three monitors and so I
said you know hey I we can't watch it
today so he's pretty sad I guess I guess
this mom won't put on my little pony
upstairs for him all right okay that's
much easier to read what do you think
about this should we try to go with the
gold or should we leave it like this all
right Nicky says team gold is better
than yellow kishore says hey Jesse
didn't post the URL for your lab coat
yet you know what I didn't I didn't
setup and grout on this computer so I I
forgot to set it up and by the time I
thought about it today I just I'd ran
out of time also I'm not sure if this
computer can handle running it since
it's so slow already so I'm gonna try to
work out a way to run and grout from
home but for now I do not have it so
sorry about that
Shana Hansen says do we get a vote for
my little pony yeah if you are my little
pony fans let me know what your favorite
pony is in the live chat or in the
comments below and be a great discussion
Oh in his ears she says hey hey and
how's it going
alright go it looks like gold is pretty
much with everybody once I don't think I
saw anybody vote for yellow okay I don't
know what color this really is yeah it's
like yellowy orange but I've just been
calling it yellow all right so let's
switch it up and do this gold I I wonder
if we should just make gold the
secondary color and the theme because it
seems like nobody's really a fan of this
color at all so let's do that let's just
switch up in the theme to gold and
that'll be cool cuz we haven't really
done any work or even looked at the the
theme in I don't know probably since it
was first put in there so let's go I
don't even remember where it is just
check it out is it here yep there it is
here's our theme so here's our secondary
wait is this a real thing
okay 500 that's interesting it's
interesting that Maine actually words
it's really weird is there somewhere
else anything
alright John says 5% darker the goal to
be easier to read it had I did I do have
a darker version of it that I've used
elsewhere that is a lot easier to read
but now I'm I'm really puzzled here so
let me I don't know if I explain why I'm
puzzled so we saw you know we can see
here that like we brought this and we
have our palette primary like light main
dark right but over here what we're
seeing is is really different than that
it's it's not it's not showing us those
options which I'm a little confused
about because how did it work when we
said main if this is what we have so I'm
wondering if we have something else
somewhere
see
got nothing here it's the last place we
could check is here so if we pulled
anything in here I guess not
all right so we are pulling from here
with yes
yeah I mean this this is where it's
pulling from okay well I guess it are
the equivalent of Maine would be this
five hundred so if we changed our five
hundred here maybe that would do
something let's see what value we're
getting right now I don't think it's
that now this is a value you know what
let me search for this value in our
project and see if if it can come up so
in Visual Studio code you can do a
search throughout all the files in your
project which is super helpful and you
can even do a replace that's how I ended
up fixing a lot of the issues when we
updated a few s theme interesting okay
so that's the color that we're getting
here
you know what I'm wondering I think it
was Harshit who did this
I wonder if Harsha took the main colors
and and then made all these variations I
mean there's probably some tool that
will make these variations for you that
that might make more sense well since we
see it here let's just let's try to
manually change this to our our gold
color which let me go my other screen
and grab the hex value for that gold
color so I do have an outdated style
guide that I made over a year ago but it
is useful to grab the hex codes so I'm
looking at that right now all right so
here's our hex code let's see if that
makes a difference and it should be
pretty obvious whether or not that's
really where the color is coming from
and if this doesn't work right now then
I'm just gonna put the hex code in
manually and just so that we can move on
and see what it looks like I can always
read through the documentation in
material UI a little bit more later and
you know try to add it into the theme
that way
okay
hey it worked awesome alright so let's
let's zoom out a bit and take a look at
it so here's that gold color what do
y'all think and I realize I'm I'm not
I'm missing things in the live chat now
so I kind of couldn't keep up there so
apologies if I am missing some advice
but anyway you all can see the gold now
my timer just went off so I'm gonna set
the five-minute timer and I'm gonna
switch back to the screen so you can
keep looking at the gold let me know
what you think okay
alright John says gold is gold is great
and he said looking good alright cool
cool cool when John says the color looks
good I believe it right because John is
an awesome artist
so guaranteed he knows way more about
colors and what looks good than than I
do so I'm gonna I'm gonna go with that
who else
Nicole says yep that's good hey Nicole
how's it going welcome to the live chat
so I think Nicole and Angie both I don't
know that I've seen you in the live chat
before apologies if you have been in the
chat and I just didn't didn't see your
message but if this is your first time
chatting thank you and thanks for
watching okay and John saying you need
that border top so okay yeah you're
you're right we're gonna put in that
border do you all remember on project
one where we did those search listings
we had a nice border who made that
border shoot somebody yet from the live
chat did some work to make that border
and I I modified it slightly but I can't
remember now I mean obviously it shows
we did in github but anyway maybe we'll
do something like that because I
I really liked that border so all right
cool we have I think this is definitely
better definitely an improvement so
we're gonna keep that and this will
match did we ever change these now we
didn't so we may want if we're going
with this color here we may want to
think about you know do we want to
change some colors here i'ma leave it
for now but you know just some some
options it just got a message from work
okay not really in this year okay and
you know what I set that five-minute
timer and then didn't answer anything in
the live chat so let me set that again
because that's not fair to you all I'm
gonna scroll up to the top of the chat
try to get through as much as I can it
looks like there's a lot in there so I
may not be able to get to it all in this
five minutes may have to wait till after
the next session and John says there he
is Bartholomew Roberts a aka blackboard
you look like a pirate on the YouTube
preview yeah what do y'all think about
that picture on the YouTube preview I
just I noticed that all my pictures
started looking the same it's just like
me smiling so I thought I'd do something
goofy and different just to kind of
break it up so yeah so I don't know if
that's too silly let me know
DT 98 says what's this project all about
I'm making a new website for the
university that I work for so it's a
small University in Ohio and their their
main you know it's it's Franciscan ddu
is the website now so we're gonna
replace that with this site it's a react
site and we get data from a wordpress
content management system we pull it in
to react using graph QL and Apollo and
we're using a material UI and following
material design guidelines pretty
closely
you know there's we have a little bit of
room you know to do our own thing here
but that's that's basically what we've
we've been working on
see
vipul says great videos but got too
boring due to unnecessary chat and slow
development alright thank you I
appreciate the input there so anyway
yeah let me know what you all think I
asked this question occasionally because
this is not the first time that we've
gotten some comments like that am I
talking too much or is that a good thing
in these videos and and I mean you know
when we stop and do the
question-and-answer stuff I do think the
slow development is an issue I think the
project sometimes are unnecessary slow
unnecessarily slow that's not always in
my control you know sometimes like in
this case the things happen and we had
to kind of stretch out the the project
so anyway not sure I that can change the
project timelines that much but I
definitely could change about the
talking so if most do you think it's ok
with the talking we'll keep going if
you'd rather me cut back on that then
I'll I'll think about doing that as well
okay Michael and Nikki are talking about
attaching color values here so you know
what I did have a plug-in that did that
an atom I don't know if I have that in
Visual Studio code oh you know what
Nikki says it does that in CSS but not
here
all right so maybe I'd have to get some
sort of separate plug-in that would
would do that also in JavaScript files
okay John says it's called color
highlight I'm not gonna install it right
now because I definitely don't need
something else running even another
plug-in while we're trying to do this so
I'm afraid it'll just freeze everything
up Chris Barker asks why are we why are
you using javascript to control CSS
yeah so in react we use JavaScript to
control everything so CSS HTML it's all
JavaScript so that's that's kind of the
reactive a to do it you can use regular
CSS and we are using that as well but
wherever we can we're using JavaScript
because that's the usual way to do
things with with reacts it's wow I
actually almost got all the way through
all these so but the timer just just
went off
all right let me I'm gonna try to
remember where I left off so I didn't
get to everything so if you ask
something I didn't get to it yet please
hang in there and then after this next
session I will answer those questions
all right so now that we have this color
here and then we still have the title we
need to do we need to do two things one
is really important and necessary the
other one I definitely want to have as
well but it's not 100% necessary so the
thing that's not 100% necessary is
making that divider between each one
we're gonna do that if we have time but
what we really need to do is we need
some way for a user to click and get to
the page right I've been thinking about
this and a thought came to me I don't
know a day or two ago and I added it in
to an issue on github so let's open up
github well well at least click to open
it up and we'll come back to it in a
second so what we'll do is we'll make
this title clickable we'll make it you
know a link and then oops alright okay I
finally opened okay cool so if I can
find this issue it will jog my memory so
I made sure I wrote it down an issue so
that I would not forget yeah here's how
we're gonna try to pull this off and and
we'll see if it works
it's under the implement search okay
so here and you all can read this to on
your own it's you know the repost public
link in the description so
we're getting the data for this you know
from the wordpress api so what we'll
have and we have already is the content
type we're bringing that in we're
already displaying that and then we're
also bringing in the slug so if we have
the content type and we have the slug
for a lot of the content that's all we
need to be able to recreate the correct
route the correct URL for this so let's
try that see if it works and then we're
probably gonna find some cases where it
doesn't work and then we can kind of
modify things to try to fit those other
cases so and if this is not making sense
to you right now it hopefully it'll make
sense once we start to actually use it
and if it still doesn't make sense after
we use it then I can explain it more
just let me know in the chat I mean
hopefully it works all right where we
add search okay so down here forget it
oops here we are okay should probably
pull this out of here so I can more
easily get to it but it's alright now
this this will probably end up being its
own component at some point so here this
span we're gonna change into an a tag
this is we're probably gonna end up
changing it into a link tag at some
point but for testing I'm fine with just
in a tag so we need an href and then our
href we're gonna put these back ticks so
that we can do a template literal here
because what we want is to do
doing wise we just want to do a slash
for now and so we're gonna have a slash
and then we're gonna use our template
literal syntax to drop into JavaScript
and actually oops my fault we need to go
into JavaScript first to be able to use
template literal syntax my fault okay if
you're not familiar with template
literal syntax put a question in the
live chat and I'll explain it it's
really cool and really useful so if you
don't know about it I'm more than happy
to explain it because I think it'll
definitely you know benefit your coding
if you know how to use it so we're gonna
try to recreate a route here so the
first thing we need is item dot what did
we call that type so item dot type and
then we're gonna put another slash and
it's gonna be
yeah anyway it just occurred to me how
many like exceptions to this rule we're
gonna have um save items outside we're
gonna have item dots slug and let's say
that and see if it works and it hasn't
refreshed yet so we'll have to give it a
second okay all right cool so I have a
few of you would like to know more about
template little syntax so the refresh
we're still waiting on the refresh so
that'll give me a second to explain it
so basically here's what you do so
anywhere that you would normally use
single quotes or double quotes in
JavaScript you can instead use that back
to key and it's the little key right
below your escape key right in the upper
left hand corner of your keyboard so it
has the little like tilde character or
it can be the back tick character so you
use that and then within it you can type
a string just like normal but you can
also put a dollar sign and then curly
brackets and within the curly brackets
you can write JavaScript so this is
useful in situations where let's say
like normally we could have done it like
this so we could have written href
equals and then you know put our normal
quotation marks and then we would have
had to put a slash and then we would
have had to put a plus sign and then our
item dot site and then the plus sign and
then our slash and then a plus sign and
then our item dot slug right well
instead of having to put all those plus
signs in different quotes we can just do
it like this
and
may not seem like we've saved a lot of
space there but if you start adding a
lot more in it definitely does save
space and the other cool thing that we
can do here is I could potentially put
in a lot of like HTML in the string with
spaces like I can hit enter here and
this would still work normally you can't
do that with strings so you can
essentially create HTML templates with
JavaScript variables in it and and use
you know indentation and line breaks
right so you could hit enter and have
them on multiple lines to make it look
like real HTML so it's very helpful
especially like if you're not using
react and you you know you just want to
make a quick you know template with some
variables in it very useful
so that's template literal syntax so you
look that up if you want a better
explanation you know I'm sure there are
probably a lot of better like blogs and
videos that explain it better than I can
but that's just kind of a brief overview
of how you would use that and why am i
getting an error trailing spaces are not
allowed okay at a trailing space all
right let's go and hopefully this is
refresh refreshed and it looks so ugly
that's fine for now I'm okay with with
it looking ugly but here's what we have
see so now now it takes us to say major
anthropology and this is Department
Biology header let's try to find it one
where this will actually work so biology
department techs there we go
so department biology probably will work
let's try it so let's click it and
hopefully I have the data in there with
the right slug no errors yet ah I know
okay so there was there
let's go back and try to find one where
it works
oh so slow I look that again let's see
see some of the times it's not gonna
work so like right here we have
Department slash departments is the URL
okay so it's not gonna work for that oh
we do have faculty this one should work
all right yeah let's click on this one
so for faculty member dr. Eric Haney I
know we have the data for him since we
used him as an example for awhile so
slow so slow so if anyone is watching
right now that is wealthy and really
impatient and you'd like this to be sped
up you can donate to the get a better
computer so Jesse can livestream faster
from home fund so let me know I can give
you my PayPal and my wallet addresses
for a variety of cryptocurrency
all right cool so that did work so this
should work for all faculty members
student profiles departments and for
majors it's going to work but it's gonna
work a little differently so essentially
there'll be two different URLs that we
can use to get to majors so what we'll
need to do to get this to work for more
things and I think the simplest way to
get it to work is just to add to our our
server and our routing function that
that translation object we're gonna have
to add some more items to that object to
have alternate URLs for certain things
that fit with this it's gonna be a
little bit weird to do that but the
alternative is I think it would be very
complicated to try to switch things
around and have like special rules for
each content type so
for now that's what what I'm gonna do
mad Duchess sorry got a jack catch y'all
later thanks Jesse
you're welcome thanks for watching I'll
see you okay
so cool so the concept works excellent
there are some cases that aren't working
properly will need to take care of that
probably won't have time this dream yeah
about 12 minutes left so I'm not gonna
get into the the more like edge cases
right now that's something I think maybe
I'd like to think about more let you all
think about it as well if you have any
ideas Michael crow says Department slash
departments work works yes sweet all
right awesome
so departments slash departments works
so maybe there won't be as many cases as
I I don't know exactly why that works
but I'm not complaining yeah Blake says
I love that idea but I don't have a lot
of money yeah I don't I'm like half
joking with that as well so like please
don't don't feel bad for me that my
computer is too slow to stream like
seriously only if there's somebody out
there that like hit it big with crypto
or something and like literally has
thousands of dollars just to throw away
like then I would I would I would accept
that okay but I don't want any of you
like you know who aren't like very
wealthy it's tempting to give me money
for something because you know like I
make enough money to support me and my
family with you know a little bit left
over so I'm not poor I don't you know I
don't need i I don't want any of you who
potentially make less money than me you
know donating to to my cause I would
just I'd feel terrible about that
so anyway um let's see a cool stuff you
just apartment
okay so Michael said it it is pulling
some data okay cool well let's yeah
let's bring this up again then and the
last thing we'll do I do I see there's
some more questions in the chat I will
get to those in about 10 minutes that
what we really ought to do now is style
this so that we don't have these really
kind of ugly old school look links so
let's style that a bit and that'll
probably all we get to today which i
think is significant you know we
actually have functional links on our
search page so let's let's go back here
and I can get rid of this and let's see
class is title so let's go up to our our
class for title here where we have our
CSS and so we still have the right font
size the right font weight so we should
only have to change the color and then
we'll set to this the text decoration to
none okay that'll get rid of our
underline and then our color should be
you know what there's probably and
that's let's let's check our color page
for whoops for material you I to see if
there's something that we should use
[Music]
where's our defaults I don't want gray
he
interesting okay so I there probably is
something within materiai that I can use
but just since we're kind of running out
of time I'm just gonna use for color
let's do RGB a and let's give it zero
zero zero right that'll give us black
wait there's no commas is there I always
want to put commas in there and it
doesn't work zero zero zero and then the
last one is our like our transparency
value so we're gonna set this to 0.87
and that's kind of the standard the
reason we want to do this instead of
just doing a grey hex value is because
now that I see that I think I should put
commas so I don't know what I'm doing
like you do a thing so many times and
it's like there are commas okay Thank
You Nietzsche and Michael says opacity
that's the word I was looking for so
opacity so anyway if you use a grey hex
color it's much harder to read than if
you use black with an opacity setting it
will look grey but it'll be much more
readable so always try to do that if you
can if you have if you want grey text
and if you don't believe me try it out
try out a grey hex right next to an
equivalent RGB a black with opacity set
that whatever to get that same color and
it's amazing the first time I tried it
and saw the difference I was wow I don't
know why I don't know why it does that
but you can check that out that's that's
I didn't invent that that's straight out
of the material design documentation
alright anyway so I guess we'll have to
wait for the reload
color yeah but that should be fine
where's our font wait while we're
waiting let's inspect this and make sure
font weight isn't there you go now it
looks like it's it's it's in there
all right cool there we are so now you
can see we have our color okay so it's
it it looks pretty dark like almost
black but it's not black and great very
cool now I mean it may not be like a
hundred percent immediately noticeable
like oh hey that's a link we'll just
have to see I'd like to maybe do some
testing with users and just tell them to
do a search and not say anything and
just see where they go to click if they
immediately go and try to click the
title I think it'll be ok if they like
try to click on something else first I
don't know we'll see maybe we'll have to
change the color let's see let me check
about four minutes all that time to wait
for an error that I knew is coming okay
well I don't I don't think I have time
to implement the that border like
between you got that little line
separating each each item so five
minutes yeah and then actually it's less
than four now so I'm just gonna go ahead
and start answering questions now so
we'll cut that Pomodoro session just a
bit short oh you know what and I always
forget to do this let's let me take the
last minute or so this session to commit
this
and then push it to github and then that
way you know you all will have a chance
to review anything that we've done and
it's a lot easier if you wanted to try
to like use some of this on your own
it's a lot easier to copy and paste from
github instead of trying to type out
what's on the video so in my terminal
which it's a little bit small there so
sorry if you can't read that right now
but I'm gonna say what I'm writing
anyway so we're gonna do a git status
just to see what we've done and we've
changed that fu s theme J s and we've
changed search J s so I always like to
verify that first and then that way if
I've accidentally changed some other
file and I don't realize it then I can I
can tell I mean it rarely happens but
occasionally you know you it does happen
sometimes so before we commit that and
mess something up always check so now
we'll do a git add and that adds those
changes to the staging area so these are
stage now ready to commit and I'm gonna
say the yarn cm and that's a special
tool that we have here that helps us to
write a good commit message if you don't
have that tool you can just type git
commit and then you can put - m and then
in quotation marks you can write your
commit message right there in line it'll
do the same thing as what we're doing
now except you'll write your commit
message all yourself instead of having
this little walkthrough so we've added
new features and what we've done is
styled style search results and we
haven't broken anything
does it change any open issues
I suppose if we want to say that
implement search issue which is 74 we
can reference that issue so let's say
yes and let's put number 74 actually
74 and they'd enter alright and now
it'll run through and we have our
project set up to do some testing and
Auto formatting of the code so if you
download this if you clone this repo and
start working on it it will auto format
your code it will Lynch your code it
will run tests so just be aware of that
it could take a while depending on the
speed of your computer so if you want to
take this project and do something else
with it on your own maybe you might want
to disable that maybe you don't like the
style we use that's totally fine but if
you are gonna try to submit code to this
project which is totally cool if you
want to do that that would be awesome
just be aware that that does need to run
because we want to keep everything
really uniform as much as possible so
you can code in whatever style you like
but then when you go to commit it will
reformat to the style that we're using
on this project which is the standard
Jas style the biggest thing you'll
notice about that is that we don't use
semicolons alright so I'm just gonna let
that go while I go back to the live chat
my Pomodoro session just ended and let
me scroll up to where I left off and
answer some questions okay so all right
so Angie says never never been before
thanks for the welcome I'm really new to
coding and I'm trying to gain confidence
Oh awesome well I I hope that this is a
place that can help you get some
confidence and yet don't worry any
questions are totally fine I
I love getting questions and I'm very
happy to explain what's going on I want
this to be as beginner friendly as
possible yeah and let me know if there's
anything I can do to make the stream
better for you
and if if it's possible I'll definitely
try it out Chris Barker says do you have
to use JavaScript to control CSS and
react no you don't you can use regular
CSS and just you know import it as
normal you could use sass if you wanted
to so yeah you don't have to use it like
that react is very flexible when it
comes to how you want to do CSS it
actually as it has so many options for
how to do CSS I guy I can't even keep
track of them all and through our
projects that we've done on the live
stream
I think we've used a different some
different way to do CSS on every one it
seems like we're always trying out
something something new
let's see - michael says Jessie during
the preview there are there are new
women in here today just saying alright
I don't Michael let me know what you
were saying that I'm not I'm not exactly
sure what you say are you saying that I
should do like my normal thing where I
tell everybody what the streams about
that I usually forget to do for the new
people anyway let me let me know I guess
it's kind of late in the stream to do
that I also remember to do it next time
though I need to just write a little
script so I can just go through it I'll
be streaming for almost a year and I you
think I would have sorted that out Jason
Lee says from Columbus Ohio Oh awesome
awesome Jason yes I'm I'm in
Steubenville Ohio so like right right
there on the border between Ohio and
West Virginia and Pennsylvania is right
there as well who is that cordelia my
one-year-old is trying to come in here
now I could do yeah she's really upset
because the door is closed so she can't
get in nikki says try giving that gold
text the CSS letter-spacing 1.4 okay
cool I'll keep in mind to mess with the
letter spacing there you got the door
open no no no come here you wanna you
wanna see data come here do you want me
to hold you no you just want to get all
my cups
uh-huh she's down here yeah do you want
to be on youtube yeah
Chaman was done all right everybody this
is Cordelia what do you say hi you say
hi wave right there wave right there
hello all right can you see can you say
hello all right what what do you want
you you want milk I don't have any milk
do you want to go upstairs and get your
milk from Mama okay go ahead go ahead
go get it good girl
alright so that was Cordelia that's my
my baby alright
sorry about that let me find my place
okay mad Dutchess says you do you no
such thing as too silly alright so that
was when I was asking if my my picture
was too silly today so thank you
[Music]
Nikki says it makes all caps a bit
easier to read if they're spaced out a
bit more oh okay cool that makes sense
that totally makes sense and it says I
like when you talk too much
all right thanks Anna I appreciate the
the input I usually when in the past
every time that somebody has suggested
that I talk less and code more I've
gotten a bunch of people say no I
actually like the talking that's what's
unique about this stream that I do take
the time to answer all the questions and
explain things so if I keep getting that
reaction then I'll keep talking
I think the Pomodoro method that we're
using here does help to keep a balance
so I guess I'll keep going with that and
for those of you that would prefer less
talking and more coding you can always
wait and watch the recordings you can
watch it on like two x speed
I've heard that I'm you can still
understand me at two times speed
probably because I don't talk very fast
normally and then you can skip the
brakes whenever I'm talking so you know
maybe that might make things a little
bit less boring for you but if it is too
boring I totally understand there's so
many other really useful videos out
there you like go you can watch those
and it it'll be fine you got to find the
tools that work for you
so I totally understand that mad Duchess
says talking is preferred it helps to
see your thought process cool Angie says
you you haven't confused me yet I think
you're fine Blake says I like the
talking development isn't slow
necessarily but it is a little during
the live streams by the way the stream
quality is good awesome okay yeah all
right well I will keep talking then okay
Angie asks with react okay cool so Jon
says you can go to react Jay s org which
is great let me give you just a brief
explanation of what react is so
certainly you'll get a better
explanation at react.js org but just for
you and anybody else that's watching
it's not familiar with react react is a
JavaScript library that allows you to
make web applications and it takes care
of a lot of the behind the scenes thing
that sometimes things that can be really
tricky so updating the state of your
application manipulating the Dom so the
document object model basically the
elements the HTML elements that are on
the page so those are just some of the
things that it does it can do a lot more
kind of behind the scenes what it's
doing is you're writing JavaScript
functions and then those functions are
adding the HTML elements to the page
but it looks still a lot like HTML
because there's this layer on top of it
called JSX that makes it way easier to
use so you can write what seems like
normal HTML but in reality you're
writing JavaScript functions so reacts
the some of the benefits of react are
you have these components that are
really easy to reuse you can have large
projects still be like manageable you
can it's fast like things happening on
the page happen really fast so I don't
want to get too in-depth as I said it
would be a short explanation but that's
that's some of what react is you've
probably seen a lot of websites that use
react Facebook users react trying to
think Instagram at least the web version
of Instagram is react I don't know if
the app is recognized for not let's see
what else is react Netflix uses react
GoDaddy's website is reacting trying to
think what uh I'm like blanking out here
but there are a lot of websites that use
react right now so if you haven't heard
of it
you know you've at least probably seen
it without even realizing Nino says is
the github thing that helps you push
better get up commits available for NPM
yeah it is
so it's commit isn't let me bring up on
the screen my package JSON file I should
just leave that file up all the time
because it seems like I always refer to
it at some point
so commit is in comm ITI ze n and then
CZ conventional changelog so those I
believe
it's those two packages that are doing
most of that and then it's tied in I
think with our pre-commit hook so the
documentation for committin should cover
a lot of what you need to set it up and
you can check out our project to see you
know how we've set it up as well but
yeah if you want to see version numbers
and stuff and copy and paste it check
out the package.json file in in this
github repo
Oh Nicky I just saw that you already
answered Nino's questions I'm sorry
about that
Thank You Nicky for answering that
okay so Nikki I didn't realize so for
those of you that use the AZERTY
keyboard instead of the QWERTY keyboard
keyboard the back tick is next to the
Enter key and it's via alt gr so for
quarter users the way I explained it
earlier is where you get it but no I
guess not so for everyone else thanks
Nikki I was not aware of that
almost to the bottom of the chat so if
you have a question you haven't put it
in there yet
get it in there quickly because once I
get to the bottom all all in the stream
and if you're watching this later on and
want to ask a question please put it in
the comments or you can ask me the
question through any social media
channel that you can find me at if you
check out the link to my youtube channel
from there I have linked all my
different social media profiles so reach
out to me however you would like it
doesn't matter to me whatever is best
for you and I'll do my best to get back
to you as soon as I can
Carlos says hi Jessi what back-end are
you using what's the setup for your
front-end sorry if you've said this
before
okay so had some some answers to this in
the live chat but let me just give a
really brief overview for everyone so
front end is react the back end is for
at least four the react stuff is we were
using nodes we're using node and express
to handle a lot of stuff a lot of
routing and things like that and then
separate from they're located on an
entirely different server is a WordPress
installation that we're just using to
handle the data we're not using any of
like WordPress themes or anything like
that
and so that's the setup so the data
database is tied in with WordPress so
essentially we just use WordPress to
manage the database so my sequel
database we pull data out of that my
sequel database using graph QL we pull
that into our react app the only
exception being on our search page we
don't use graph QL we just use the
standard REST API for WordPress Niq yes
when I was talking about the difference
between grey text and black text with
opacity at I mean we use values like
0.87 for normal text 0.5 for 4 for input
text but nikki says what's the reason it
looks more readable better anti-aliasing
or something I'm telling truth I'm not
really sure michael says just a guess
but it's not as hard as a solid gray
since it's slightly see-through it could
be michael says just realize you're
using the second terminal michael says
no the picture what picture oh I know
now so when you're talking about explain
the preview all right yeah so so the
preview thumbnail for the video I took a
goofy picture of my face because just to
switch things up like because I normally
just take the same type of picture of
just me smiling so anyway I just thought
I'd be goofy today to change things up
this is like somewhat of a serious
stream those
Angie says my brother lives in Yellow
Springs at i/o okay cool yeah it's
always fun to learn where people are
from because sometimes it's like find
out people are actually like close to
where I'm at or like really cool one day
I think it would be super awesome to
have some type of meetup for all the
people that like watch the stream either
like maybe if I'm traveling somewhere
and it's in a location where a lot of
you are or something like that
I mean maybe it'll just be every time I
travel somewhere I'll let you all know
where I'm going and anybody that's close
we can just like hang out or something
if any of you would be up for that let
me know I just think it'd be fun like to
actually hang out in person at some
point since I mean like we we spent a
lot of time together online doing these
streams so it would be it would be kind
of cool Kishore says how to make a react
app into a progressive web app which is
popping up on dev hey baby you wanna be
on YouTube okay yeah so kiss was talking
about that yes so there is a recent
article I didn't read it yet
but it does talk about how to turn a
react app in a progressive web app yeah
so check that out if you're interested
in that it is actually really easy so
we've done it before
so if you check out most of the projects
that we've done that's actually been
done usually harsh it takes care of that
but yeah it's it's just a few extra
lines and it's really cool so I see a
lot of you were saying hi to Cordelia
and saying she was cute so thank you
thank you appreciate it yeah I
love that little girls poor spoiler so
much I hope she turns out all right but
she's just my baby and she just she
wants me to hold her all the time I just
can't like I can't say no to her she's
so cute
Carlos says hello from Switzerland hey
how's it going hey and this is uh this
is Gemma this is my oldest daughter
you say hi Gemma and Gemma
maybe wants to be a coder too when she
grows up I think I might get a coding
Club today you gonna go to a coding Club
today I think so I think it's tomorrow
morning yeah so a coding Club tomorrow
yeah well I'm yeah I'm not gonna code
I'm gonna come with you and hang out and
help you out yeah you can hang out here
while I'm doing this if you want or you
can go play I have students on like I
mean you need a book and then you have
to take a test on the on the Chromebooks
on the book and you're not allowed to
look at the book no I pretty much always
get good job baby
yeah gemma is very smart and always gets
good grades one time I got see I see
that happens sometimes that's okay in
what I thought I gotta see but it was
actually Charley's paper yeah okay all
right well if you wanna stay down here
I'm gonna finish this soon so I got to
answer a few more questions okay hey you
got McDonald's car
I got McDonald's coffee this morning
after I took you to school all right let
me answer these questions okay
sorry about the the camera moving so I'm
gonna try to get a stationary camera
soon I don't want to make any of you
motion sick okay Oh Anna says I enjoy
your English oh thank you
I guess I guess it's okay I tried yeah
you remember Anna you talk to her speak
English she was the one who said she was
gonna teach me the other language I
think yeah try not to move around a lot
you actually making me motion sick I get
motion sick very very easily just like
[Music]
Nicky says visual studio code tip
control clicking on a component name
brings you to that file interesting
let's let's try it that sounds really
cool so I'll see if I own a name I may
not have my own component name in here
or component in here at all I should try
index s that's probably where I have
okay so that's control no didn't work
for me let me check commands and
something that command click hmm okay
didn't work for me yeah Dickens they can
see it this is what they see on the
screen
yeah alright michael says regarding
graph QL oops my window my chat window
just jumped down to the bottom so I lost
track where it was there we go
so Michael says regarding graph QL I've
sort of gotten a hand on it but can't
figure out how to connect the the test
WordPress database you set up I can hard
code the search result URL but not
search your main URL so do I need that
admin rights to do the search on
WordPress or is there a graph QL plugin
that I might need you know what you
could let him into your thing well we
could let me let me I'm trying to think
over this look at that problem could be
so times a mess mess everything up but
okay so you're saying so the search
results worked for you but the graph QL
stuff doesn't is that let me know cuz
like the the search uses the REST API so
that should work right off the bat with
any WordPress instance it should be fine
the graph the graph QL should work - I'm
I'm not sure why it wouldn't be working
I don't have any like restrictions or
limitations set on it at least not right
now
right next to your computer let me
answer these questions then we can talk
okay what other questions
there's already
there's more question see yeah so
they're waiting for me to answer the
question so I don't want to make them
wait for too long okay that's a total
question all right well let's get
through let's say it says them awesome
also users react cool very cool Blake
says I ended up getting a surface pro 2
again ok cool Blake let me know how that
goes for you and how you like it
sighs si I I'm not sure I pronounce that
let me know if I pronouncing it wrong
but anyways I says learning a lot of
things awesome I'm super glad whenever
somebody learned something from these
streams I imagine that you all don't
always learn it from me there's a lot of
really smart people in the live chat
giving some some good information but as
long as you learn something yeah smarter
than me think about it web document
[Music]
let's see Nicki says I was watching a
tutorial in the instructor used it
without mentioning it my mind was
blowing him so cool ok that was the the
tip in Visual Studio code that I
couldn't get to work but I'm probably
just doing something wrong so I'll have
to try it again later yeah you know what
there's coffee grounds in the bottom so
you can I didn't even realize there's
anything left I thought I drank it all
if you don't if you don't want the
coffee grounds it's fine
ok I'll drink it like a demo remember
we're gonna talk later ok all right
thank you
my shoes can't carry on tiring school
okay well you have to you have to double
not them well not double on mine okay
your weekend we can test sets out some
knocks later okay uh-huh
dev more says hi new here and to react I
was wondering if it's a good idea to go
through your earlier projects it could
be the only thing about some of the
earlier projects are so I've been
streaming for almost a year now so some
of the things that we did early on are
outdated so you know a lot of the
packages that we've used have new
changes and and some of the changes are
breaking changes even react mist has
come you know when we started this that
was pre react 16 can it wait
so anyway you can look you can probably
still get some good info from the
previous projects but just be aware that
some of that stuff may be outdated so if
you're ok with that then yeah go ahead
and watch some of the previous stuff I
probably do a better job of explaining
things earlier on and like as I've gone
on I kind of just stopped explaining
like the same thing over and over again
why don't you write down what you want
to say so you don't forget and then we
can talk about it after the world says
did you become a remote worker I yeah so
I'm semi remote right now so I'll
probably be spending like a few days a
week at home a few days in the office
Carlos says thanks for explaining very
intricate back-end routing and stuff
from WordPress to no js' Express and
then react cool yeah it's it's a little
bit more complicated than probably most
University websites are but I think
there is
alts are gonna be you don't get on my
computer I'm alright with that yeah so I
think the results gonna be a very fast
and flexible website John says Jessie
have you seen the movie brainstorm a
scary precursor to your new headset I
haven't seen it they have to check it
out if it's on Netflix I'll check it out
yeah actually so I got the headset in
the mail today so if if you want to know
more I have a project where I'm gonna
work with a brain-computer interface to
try to help my son Rafael with his his
mental illness obsessive-compulsive
disorder and get some anxiety yeah you
can use it too well I'm gonna be working
on that project I'll probably be putting
some videos on my own YouTube channel
about it so if you're interested you can
subscribe to my youtube channel the
links in the description and I'll be
doing videos on that soon I'd like to
work on it like later today and tomorrow
if I can so anyway I don't know
hopefully I can help my son
and then maybe help other people too if
it works but anyway if you want to know
more about it watch yesterday's stream
because I explained more in depth what I
want to do and there is a conversation
on Twitter of more about it too so if
you want to check out my Twitter it's
it's somewhat recent tweet there's a
kind of a big conversation going on
there Blake says the meetup would be
cool cool cool that's well I'll
definitely let you all know whenever I'm
going right now I'm the closest big city
I am that I'm to is Pittsburgh so there
is you Genesis to LA you see there red
for the microphone thing we don't want
it to get to the red
except there are I try to bowl okay
remember you're gonna write down gonna
write no no you're gonna hurt
everybody's ears I'm gonna I might have
to turn down the mic here let me turn it
down a bit hopefully you can still hear
me
yeah Jim and Jill I'm not gonna let you
be down here for these if you don't quit
talking okay and you don't shake the
chair maybe I like having you on here
but you gotta listen okay Oh
anyway if anybody is in or around the
Pittsburgh area now or if you're ever
traveling around there definitely let me
know because it wouldn't be that hard
for me to drive up and you know meet up
there all right Blake's in Upstate South
Carolina cool I may be in Charleston
later I'm thinking about going to a
conference in Charleston I haven't
bought tickets yet though but I'll let
you know if I go I mean I know
Charleston isn't isn't really upstate
but it's closer than where I am now
you think I'm rich remember we're gonna
write down our ideas of what we want to
talk about write them down oh yeah John
says basically create react app
out-of-the-box builds a progressive web
app automatically yeah you know what you
are right John
that's true like you have everything you
need for oppressive weather yeah right
mr. John University hosts a conference
and pay for us to get there it really
wouldn't be that many people think how
much we could do on a hackathon over the
over a weekend actually that's a great
idea
[Music]
so I had an idea and I presented it to
my department Tuscon Jim why don't you
go play in the other room and I'll come
get you when I'm done nope tell me I'm
saying you're gonna hurt everybody's
ears when you scream like that cuz they
probably have headphones on okay I don't
want you hurting everybody's ears all
right okay you're not gonna get any
gummy bears if you scream anymore okay
no gummy bears all right so here was my
idea an idea to start a boot camp like a
coding boot camp a code school at
Franciscan so it wouldn't be for
actually you know university credit and
that would actually be an advantage
because being accredited and all that
means like we'd have to have people with
masters and PhDs teaching and the
process to get courses approved is
really really slow but if we did it as
this separate entity kind of like
catechetical Institute did that site
that we did for them they're an
institute people don't get real degrees
through there they get a certificate it
would be somewhat like that but it would
be tied in to Franciscans so since I
wouldn't be like a real professor
I could teach there or you know other
people you know could teach that don't
necessarily need to have a degree so
anyway I thought it would be cool and
then we could branch out like start with
web dev stuff but branch out into maybe
like some other cool things like machine
learning and then that way like I don't
know I think it could be useful I think
people might might like that and it
could be good for the university too so
I just need to tell the right people I
guess and get it started probably find
donors who are willing to donate think
it started as well
but I think it'd be cool all right I'm
gonna read it after after Jim and Angie
said hello and John said hello Carlos
[Music]
you sound smart who said that mr. Johnny
hi mr. Johnny what's up hey how's it
going thanks for joining in the live
chat in ask what's the tech Gemma which
your shirt's a CCHS
okay that's the yeah the Catholic Church
the Catholic High School here in steve-o
is Catholic Central High School and the
mascot is the tree shaders so CCHS
Crusaders Michael says my youngest has
autism along with ADHD so your project
sounds interesting
oh yeah I mean I I don't have any
medical background I don't have
experience with this yet but I did I
don't know I the idea makes sense that
it could happen it just it's just a
matter of if I can get reliable consist
I might have to cool stuff regards from
El Salvador hey how's it going let's see
JavaScript it says hey I was born and
lived till age four in Charleston oh you
probably don't remember that much if you
left at age four but I think Charleston
is one of my favorite cities really
beautiful city especially in the spring
[Music]
[Music]
lakes is do I get a name yes not she
left
Blake's his family reunion Blake also
said hey Jesse that sounds like a cool
project what language are you using
we're actually gonna use JavaScript so
Alex Castillo has done a lot of work
with us already and he has some github
repos where he's able to get the data
and use javascript to display it like on
a website
kind of web app so that's it's this
we're gonna use it's gonna be cool and
all right so I've got in the bottom a
live chat so I'm gonna end this cordelia
you wanna say goodbye say goodbye to
everyone say bye bye no bullying Savage
is this year so Jesse I always wish the
streams I'm sorry about that hopefully
you can you can make it first stream
sometime soon
all right so I am going to I am gonna
end this dream and oh it's Friday I was
about to say I'll be back tomorrow it's
Friday so I'll be back on Monday if I
have time and I work on that head set
project the brain computer interface
thing this weekend and maybe I'll do a
stream on that on my channel we'll see
how it goes I'd like to do at least a
video from my channel sometime soon so
if I hopefully I'll have time if not
I'll see you all on Monday yeah until
then I have a wonderful weekend and
thank you all so much for watching and
for all your advice in the live chat
really appreciate it as always and I
can't find the button to stop the
streams alright I'm leaving for Rio now
see ya